Kids And Technologies.
Kids today are growing up completely accustomed to technologies.
Often, they give absolutely no thought as to how a particular technology works...
...or what mechanism is behind it.
They just take the technological advancements for granted.
A good example is my niece, who is 10 years old.
She visited me and wanted to watch her favorite TV show.
The show was on a cable channel, but I didn't have cable.
She did not understand why she couldn't watch her show when there was a TV in my house.
I told her I would sign up for cable,...
...so that by the time it gets under way, she could watch her show at my place, too.
She had no idea what that meant at all.
Although my niece's example is extreme, with her being young and all,...
...I see similar things with older kids as well.
For example, my teenage nephew can use the computer and knows how to properly shut it down and all,...
...but doesn't really understand how it works.
It's funny that kids have very little understanding of the underlying technology...
...while at the same time are very proficient at using it.
What's even funnier is that as soon as their favorite TV show kicks off,...
...they are quiet as mice,...
...staring at the TV screen without a thought of the world around them.